[Music]
when i was younger i used to love
catching frogs was maybe my favorite
activity going to the local pond and
catching frogs and toads and
occasionally if i was really lucky at
turtle um and one day i found two toads
that were stuck to each other
being the good samaritan amphibian
samaritan that i am i took them home
and uh i tried to pull them apart which
i did successfully and
i left them in in a little
tank to recuperate overnight and the
next day they were uh
floating belly up
dead it was uh really traumatic for me
and
um i thought i was helping them and
to too many years later i i realized
what my mistake was you know it's good
you learned that lesson then and in that
way with those animals
instead of later with humans
oh my god what are they doing
no get off of them um yeah
i know
it's yeah it could have turned out a lot
worse for me it was but but those now
i'm picturing you ripping two humans
apart who are having sex
who are you picturing i don't want to
tell you okay oh god life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is
my um still slightly sick uh covety
brother christian hello
uh how are you how are you feeling
i'm feeling okay
thanks for asking
well you know i've been asking you
constantly every time you cough i
get a little nervous um
but you're doing okay and uh your
girlfriend maggie uh who
also had it is doing much better and
we are coming to you from a very gloomy
connecticut uh our little podcast studio
very rainy and i just heard some thunder
which is cool it is cool thunder's still
exciting you don't both have to like
thunder
um
yeah you know when when i pulled those
two unfortunate toads those horny toads
apart uh
by the way should we clarify what they
were doing for anyone
i guess we don't have to they're mating
yeah okay yeah they were making love um
they were making they were mating love
uh
but
my i remember thinking
you know mama
now i'm thinking mom and posh should
have said something at the time do they
know you were doing it yeah yeah i i
remember telling them um
my mom definitely i said oh these two
are stuck together it was a perfect
opportunity to tell tell me about the
birds and the bees you were 15 16
i was uh
i forget how old i was but i
i was probably
way too old to to not know do you know
who else likes amphibians oh right
that's why we're talking about this yeah
i do our guest today david harbour did
you know that before no no idea did
couldn't you hear the excitement in my
voice in the shot both of your voices
we'll get that okay okay okay um yes our
guest today is david harbour and um
amphibian lover yeah david harbor that's
right he's which is he's mostly known
for um
and
stranger things have happened than uh
realizing that's what somebody
also loves frogs uh yeah it's um david
is somebody that i have seen on many an
episode of stranger things you may also
have what a
terrible sentence i just said you know
i'm ashamed to admit this but
grammatically i've only seen the first
season of stranger things and it's i
don't both have to only have seen the
first season of strangers
i don't understand why because i i know
i loved it me too and i i remember when
the first season ended i was like
i i i was like desperate for more you
know such a great cliffhanger i just
never saw it
it's almost like if all of the seasons
had been released or if you had just
been late to the party you would have
seen oh absolutely that's what happened
with friday night lights breaking bad
and from oh and breaking bad yeah that
happened to me you don't both have to do
a binge breaking bad in the same exact
way uh yeah that happened with i was
like season five or six on breaking bad
before i discovered it yeah i just did
me too them all at the same time um but
i do i i should and i will uh and i
still really want to see the rest of it
because that first season's so great and
he is
amazing he is such a
and he was an actor you
knew of uh yeah i had known of him and i
and i guess we had run into each other
years earlier uh which i didn't
remember but um of course i was always
aware of him i had seen a lot of his
work he was always to me like a very
reliable
character actor that would pop up and
um i always enjoyed watching but i think
stranger things is the thing that i mean
obviously that's that thing that really
like brought him to everyone that's the
stranger thing that brought him to
people's attention yeah well
it's tempting isn't it yeah
i hope you're not rubbing off on me
oh thanks um well we have been
quarantined together for 15 days it's
true and if there if there's ever a time
to catch up on some
binge-worthy shows
like stranger things uh now we should
watch it now is the time yeah for sure
he's also playing um
the villain right in black widow the new
black widow movie comes out so cool
hopefully it comes on may still uh we'll
see where we are with the quarantine but
but i feel like they're releasing even
the movies that are supposed to come out
in the theaters they've been releasing
on
oh really done to me i'm sorry even a
big like a big marvel movie like that
sorry uh-oh no no i just
coffee went down the wrong way i i don't
know this was the last one i think we
did right before
the
our quarantine um
so was my last day in new york city and
uh
i hope you enjoy it my chat with
the very funny very talented frog loving
david harbor
[Music]
david's coming into the into the studio
i'm just gonna i'm telling everyone
what's happening what are we uh are we
lying yeah yeah this good stuff i don't
want to waste time oh don't waste it
it's too good this is gold
so repeat everything you just said so
basically i have my good theories about
the coronavirus right i mean that's why
you called me out here an expert on
you're also an actor i know
i decided mainly it's pandemics you're
so you just came in from london just
came from london uh and and they didn't
seem all that concerned with yeah i'll
tell you the guy
uh the customs guy who
by the way they never checked when you
go through customs they never like grab
you and check your bags do they when you
go like um you know i was working a job
in london last year and they would do it
in london
because i'd have these one way i was
going through a breakup and i wanted to
be home a lot so it was like it was
like a small part so i'd work you know
three days and i i'd have four days off
so it was just enough where i'd want to
go
back to the states you know what is this
the movie that i want to talk about the
jade and son of mama no oh do you want
to know are you in that as well
everyone's saying that no no i wish so
please come on they don't call me for
things like that i'm new to the club
anyway so i'm in the thing i i'm walking
through the customs right no nothing to
declare
and as i'm walking towards the customs i
put sunglasses on and i think that's why
the guy points out come here buddy
hey big shot
yeah it was more like those red eyes
this is a great equalizer or whatever
yeah so he scanned my bags and i just
was like how big is this coronavirus
thing like what's the real oh you asked
him oh yeah yeah i was like on the
ground and i promised him i wouldn't
wouldn't tell him that i wouldn't tell
anyone that he said this well but it's
good there's nothing for you no i don't
think we're recording
and even if we were i don't think anyone
really listens to yeah exactly so and
this is just a draw they probably fall
asleep at this point don't be able to
put podcasts on and then just sort of
drift away i think so
i've heard that people like i listen to
you to fall asleep
thank you it's very flattering
so yeah uh so he said
they had um
i was like how serious is this he's like
you want some inside information i was
like yeah
inside everything
you're sunglasses yeah i did i did come
on because i knew we had a connection
and he was like
we had 16 guys coming yesterday from
wuhan china wuhan china i was like whoa
right anyway
16 guys apparently uh detained in
ukraine for like 10 days on a quarantine
but then came straight here
so this guy calls
again i'm not legally responsible for
anything that's not sure by the way this
could be a lie that i mentioned
so he said
he called the cdc and the guys were like
man whatever
which made him believe that
it's not that big of a deal
uh or the thing is just
too late or it's too late whatever it's
like they don't want the guys on the
front line to get
at that point we're already screwed as i
don't know why they don't want any
responsibilities we seem to think it was
just like a cold and we're good
that's what i'm hoping i'm hoping it's
one of those because you know we've been
through the avian bird thing the stars
and
uh those all turned out to be but yes we
did i don't really remember that as
dramatically as this is that just
because i'm older or is that because uh
of social media like why is it well
maybe both but i bet social media has
has a lot to do with it do you know what
i also saw was uh cause i was looking at
statistics h1n1 do you remember that i
don't even remember that yeah but it was
like a big one
millions of people
and was that lethal was that uh this is
fun i think maybe it was less lethal
this is a comedy pie i know well you
know what's funny is
well speaking of lethal there's nothing
funny my my grandmother was a guest on
you're following in big footsteps
because my grandmother was 103 survived
spanish flu and and she told these crazy
stories about how
her whole family got it her are those
like kids with david's i just want to
illustrate david's uh headphone has
completely fallen off its uh
mount do you guys think that's true yeah
no that's not gonna totally can be fixed
um it's funny that you were in the
elevator and everybody was talking about
because i i rode up in the elevator and
had this experience where everyone
moved away from each other as soon as
somebody would get off you know they'd
all just kind of like make the perfect
amount of space
uh in the there were like five people
two would get off and the three would
just separate perfectly yeah this was uh
it was there was a
i did notice this which i couldn't as a
almost as a political statement i went
against it the guy touched the button uh
floor nine with his uh iphone he
wouldn't use his finger but it doesn't
even but now it's on there
yeah but i i went in with with full i
was like literally
full finger i was like i will not let it
destroy i'm gonna do it with my tongue i
will go wash my hands but i will not let
us destroy this moment yeah we're better
than that yeah you know
i mean i will say the number look
i mean i kind of get it i kind of don't
like the numbers are what is the case in
new york it's like 200. i know in new
york city there are eight million people
i know right so the odds of
you being infected are
you less than getting eaten by a shark
in midtown i know now they are but now
yeah do you know there's this horrible
video i mean now it's horrible i used to
think it was fun to play
you actually are a virus and you're
trying to spread and infect the whole
world
and so you get these upgrades of like
you can become airborne or you can like
have certain mutations
so you play the virus
yeah it's a video game you look like a
fire used to be really fun when like
none of this was good yeah when virus is
dead this was a theoretical about
humanity and now it's like how could you
play that oh my god well i think that
about some movies about are people going
to go see
movies like um
that are about humanity ending or about
any sort of apocalyptic thing um
i don't know
i mean you have one coming out i have
one coming out not really about the end
of the world but there is a
there is uh some forms of
not really yeah more about superheroes
and things like that a really funny
thing happened on my way here i was
leaving and i was thinking about what
should i wear which i rarely do what
should i
wear
oh i'm honored dave is an important
guest david's like a big i wanna you
know we'd take a picture for instagram
i'm like i'm gonna look nice first yeah
and i and i leave the house i have this
i have my favorite like checkers they
all kind of look the same yeah it's not
this and i'm leaving and uh
and i go i a couple of steps into my
walk to the to not to the subway to here
i was going to walk directly here and
i'm like i have plenty of time i'm going
to be early
and i think oh it's a little chilly out
i'm like i should go back and put on
some i should grab a light jacket
so i'm walking back and this guy's
approaching me this kind of strange
looking older man and he's staring at me
and i'm thinking this guy's weird does
he suspect that maybe i have
you know
that i have it that i'm infected or i
don't know my mind was starting and as
i'm thinking this and thinking i gotta
change and i'm happy with my shirt this
um
i i droplets is too
is not strong enough a word it was like
um
something cascaded down on me
um i thought somebody had
like tossed out
a soup or something from a top
it was bird [ __ ] a bird [ __ ] on one of
the
easily the most bird [ __ ] i've ever been
covered with uh i tried to take a photo
of it wow it was the craziest thing and
it was like it made like a it didn't
make like a droplet center made like a
like a
like a you know it was like
it was crazy hailstone yeah it was like
uh i couldn't quite capture it um
but look at this that's just part of it
it's hard to see oh my god micros all
over my hair
good luck
congratulations but i was thinking about
like all the things i've been paranoid
about and
you know wanting to avoid i mean look at
that wanting to avoid shaking hands it's
all over my shoulder it was all in my
bag to wash my bag yeah um and then you
think you just can't avoid it you can't
avoid certain things yeah you know
you're just getting god thank god i
wasn't like huh you know like looking up
with my mouth open
i mean it's it's a funny thing like it's
it's also because i read a lot about
zombie apocalypses because i'm convinced
that in 10 years with climate change
like
we will be in some form of a minor
zombie apocalypse where like you know
there's like near future stuff where
like let's say
four bridges go out from manhattan it
gets hard to get food in here and like
things start to deteriorate like the
social
uh there's a reason why those movies are
fun and successful because it's they're
not like
that far off from potentially happening
yeah and they're sort of how-to guides
as opposed to movies
but i mean one of the things is i do
know that as uh
because there's all this speculation of
like what do you need and i was like oh
maybe you you know
buy a gun and you pretend but i guess
what happens is we all kind of have to
make it through together like the best
skills in any apocalyptic scenario are
social skills and the ability to
be useful in a group
yeah um you seem like you would be
really good to have on your team
no skills really zero skills can't even
fish oh really well yeah
seriously
i mean you seem rugged and outdoorsy and
capable i'm kind of big
i could and i'm also angry okay like
deep down inside this like killer rage
in me so yeah i suppose i could be like
a yeah you know defensive linebacker for
the uh for the group for the team yeah
but i was thinking about that the other
day and i was like you know it's funny
we are actors right like we're
entertainers so
at the high culture level
we have a lot of skills and we in fact
are very high in demand yeah and then as
culture begins to break down things like
doctors become a lot more important
we're very dispensable yes yeah us and
like lawyers like nobody really at a
certain point law and entertainment and
culture fail and influencers yeah you
know that i guess they're the first
irony of like as we've moved forward
forward i do think the younger
generation is like how do i get famous
like how do i get famous like how do i
be an influencer like that's the last
yeah just know how to like fix a tire
and like you'll be great during the
climate i mean some of the things i'm
most grateful for are the things i
learned in boy scouts how to you know
any sort of not tying or getting fresh
water or
i'm surprised you don't know about that
well no no actually i am i am very
grateful for
growing up you know like i look at the
kids on my show right and they don't
have uh they don't they stopped at like
11 or 12. and like now they're hollywood
like i was up until 25
i didn't know much of that world so yeah
you know i was like fixing cars with my
dad so like i can fix a car like as long
as it's a block engine and like no fuel
injection like a fuel pump and like yeah
me too if it's fuel injection
i don't know what you thought yeah
already i knew i knew that you had some
of those no i do have something and also
i did do like woodworking growing up i
can do some carpentry
all right all right all right it's fine
but i haven't done it in like 20 years
yeah well you've been before now i
stopped yeah because i because you
started started
you know jay and silent
it's so funny if kevin smith knew that
you actually wanted that call he he
probably didn't call you because he was
like there's no way he's going to want
to do this
damn i just it was actually just i don't
even know if i wanted the call but when
i saw the type of work you were doing in
that movie i was jealous oh see you know
i was like i love that performance oh
thanks man i you know that it's a
character i did in zack and mary and uh
it was really disappointing because this
movie zach and mary make a porno i
played it and he was a gay porn star he
was very like hypersexual
and he was like he hits on seth roge and
he's dating brandon routh and he's like
he's just very aggressively sexual he
he's one of those gay guys that like
hates he is like an aversion to the
thought of a vagina right you know what
i mean like
oh my god awful like the thought of it
you know
just so he was that kind of guy and then
kevin asked me to play the same
character in this thing oh he did so
that was his thing that's funny because
i was like where did he come up with
well the problem with it is he's a
lawyer in this thing that you saw right
and um and so that's why we're gonna get
into our movie pitch right okay oh yes
yes yes drama this is really what you're
doing yeah well no but so the he was a
lawyer yeah well but it didn't really
make any sense so they cut out all the
um aggressively sexual stuff that like
joe manchinella was the bailiff for
example joe is a really hand you know
he's like a hot chick i could tell there
was stuff that was cut out all the fun
joe doesn't get to do anything
i know he just says like here we go
it's like he's like later in the course
clearly he had more but i'm surprised
that that stuff was
what was it too much well for that movie
i know
kevin explained that uh it didn't really
make sense because we don't
know what was the logic we don't explain
it it's not explained it's not like does
it matter i know i know here's what i
think i think it wasn't funny well yeah
maybe it just wasn't funny i think it
was ten years ago we did that character
who was like grabbing people and like
when he was like
yeah yeah it doesn't work it's not quite
as funny anymore so yeah yeah
but but all the stuff i did with joe it
was fun on the day and it was fun when
we did it it was like really fun to do
because he he was also like mildly
uncomfortable with it you know it wasn't
it was whatever so it was so does that
make you like lean in a little of course
brandon when we did the original acting
man just let me go yeah come on and the
cameras are rolling i know it's fun
it's really funny
um what uh what you look at the first
thing i notice about you because i i
only saw you a couple months ago was
that yeah yeah maybe a couple months ago
you cut all your hair yeah yeah and i
also did a little um
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're ready for the
apocalypse yeah well basically i mean
it's for the new season of the show i
saw the trailer yeah yeah so
i'm behind
well uh okay but but i know that there's
there's uh fourth season coming up but
yeah i'm halfway through the second
season oh okay i'm behind uh at this
point you still have a full beard and uh
and
a lot happens to him yeah yeah
in russia on a chain gang that's what it
is that's what the trailer is you it
came out on valentine's day it did yeah
yeah cause you know yeah we love you um
but yeah it's uh
he's like in rush on this on this change
and basically the in season three i had
gotten
really big
uh and it's
one of the things kind of about him is
he he sort of stops drinking so much he
certainly stops doing those two and all
pills that he was doing in season one
and um you you got big for the show yeah
and so he yeah so he's like on the couch
eating tostitos chips like dealing with
the uh cortisol problems of dealing with
a teenage daughter basically yeah you
know like stuffing his feelings because
he can't go out and get drunk so right
yeah so i got really big in the third
season you see it like i'm bigger in the
second season the third season i get
really big they told you i mean i know
it's the character but how much do they
do they say a specific number we want
you to hit no no i mean it's something
where it's like it's a funny thing i
mean i don't know if i should even if i
i wonder if i throw them on i don't
think they would care
but i
it's almost like we come up with stuff
together like they have an arc of the
show we know where the show is going to
go they know where the show is going to
go
the duffer brothers but as we get there
our seasons seem to stretch out a little
bit longer like at first it was supposed
to be just like three seasons and now we
have like four and oh it was probably
yeah so
so they from even before the first
season aired it was always meant to be
yeah oh they want to do a trilogy or
like but now it's there's more room
because they want to do some more yeah
yeah which is great like because i i
think it's it's not it's not like the
fans love it so much it's like you don't
wanna if you got more in you like go
ahead and do it but in that way it
allows us a little more freedom and so a
lot of times we'll just come up with
things
and oh cool one of the things was like
wouldn't it be cool
to have
uh this particular arc with him and so
yeah so it was something that we came up
with on the fly and as as you're going
you're like can you get a little bigger
like should we do and you're like yeah
yeah let's try that yeah and then this
going into this season it was really
important to um
you know would be really strange if i
lost all this weight yeah yeah yeah but
it's it's it happens because of
something like he's almost resurrected
in this season
in a different way and
you'll see there because i think you may
have heard or something but the end of
season three like
people yeah
do i spoil it for you no no
yeah people will know people who know
will know but i you don't want me this
is very nice it's a podcast
but i love the show so much that i don't
i don't want to hear it okay yeah well
he dies you die is that what you're
saying
there was something happened and there
is like sort of a
a resurrection you spent a long time
living a very different life oh okay was
there any reservation that you had in uh
about signing up for three seasons and
now becoming four or five were you
at all reserved about that no no no
i mean it's funny like because i was at
a place in my career where first of all
we didn't know it'd be three seasons
like yeah i have to say like shooting
the first season we thought we would we
thought that was it oh really yeah like
netflix didn't seem that into it like
nobody seemed that into it they didn't
really advertise it
funny oh yeah we thought we were gonna
be just a bomb oh that's funny i had the
opposite experience where last year i
did this big production oh yeah abc
co-production i'm like oh netflix is
gonna love this and they put it out
no advertising no and i don't think
anything's happening with it i think
it's it gets you know if people don't
see it
it just gets buried uh
well that that's been always the case
with me is that those projects where
everybody's patting themselves on the
back and being like this is going to
change your life pal it's like
no phone calls yeah so you learn after a
while yeah i mean i learned to be
extremely cynical like yes and just to
feel like you just show up to work i
mean yeah and you just do what you can
but i had no expectations
um
the
i thought it was an amazing script when
i read it and i thought those guys were
really talented and it's one of those
things where i was kind of in a position
in my career where i was like
you know
i was sort of doing a bunch of theater
but i'd given up on the idea that i
would do anything of substance in film
and television huh
you know you had done revolutionary
wrote you would yeah
but i had always been like
kind of supporting yeah like six or
seven on the call sheet yeah or uh
and
and what it started to devolve into
was like
you know not even that complex stuff in
revolutionary road it was more like just
running down a hallway like chasing
denzel with a gun yeah
yeah yeah you know and then like the
minor character moment that maybe we
need and that probably will be cut out
yeah like um as much as i love him like
noah emmerich you know you see guys like
that yeah no exactly exactly around and
yeah reliable and solid but sorry but
they and they pop up every once in a
while but they just pop up they pop in
yeah um and that's i think what how i
had conceived conceived of you like as
yeah exactly yeah um
but but even though you had done great
theater work uh you were always such a
reliable actor but
it must after at a certain point you
must say to yourself yeah uh well it's
just like where you put your heart you
know what i mean like i i in theater
like i could still be like a leading man
i could play parts that were complex and
rich and interesting and yeah and then
in hollywood i just was like okay you
guys want me to be kind of this like
two-dimensional like thing it's fine i
need the money like i need to pay my
rent because i can't pay at an off-broad
like at the vineyard theater making 350
a week i think i can't live in manhattan
yeah but yeah so it would be like law
orders and then it would be like these
parts in movies and i was kind of like
that's what i'll be but i'm not going to
put my heart into this stuff anymore
because i've been disappointed so much
what what what was one that really
was a good example of that it was
revolutionary road yes to a certain
degree that was more
it wasn't so much that
i don't know what happened with that
whole thing but i sort of thought that
would launch me in a way that you didn't
i remember even like that movie black
mass i did yeah
where it was like a significant part
yeah but it still feels like
sort of a character piece that i thought
it was going to be right and it is that
thing too where you you see as you say
like you go see the final movie yeah and
you're like oh that's what that was like
i just recently had one of those where
you're just like oh i didn't agree to
that i don't know why i keep getting
scammed into like thinking that we're
making this movie yeah and then you wind
up realizing it's entirely a director's
vision and you don't know anyone until
you know them and even then you don't
know right so they can come up and go
like no no actually you're the color red
right you're like i thought we were
playing like a blue green bunch of
colors like yellow
oh i'm just red yeah okay funny yeah so
to a certain degree even stranger things
was like
this is beautiful this is amazing but
like in the pilot but i don't know
that i'll get it and also i don't know
that i can put myself into it when i did
finally get it i was like i did say to
myself i'll give it one sort of last try
on that first season to just go
as
crazy as i could like to go as dark as i
could yeah and see what that yields put
my heart into it and it yielded so much
that i was like reinvigorated i was like
oh i can be in movies and tv oh that's
interesting and what happened to those
kids after us after a year i mean all
those kids like you said they
yeah i mean they all things change and
um things change yeah yeah oh
stranger things happened yeah the other
day how many more of those you got in
here yes all right uh
probably
maybe two or three oh my god but it was
like overnight right i mean wasn't it it
was overnight yeah yeah it was crazy
like even with you know i've never seen
anything like that like i was doing a
play at the public i was doing charles
and crescent in the park and it came out
on a friday night and i remember like
you're like this place popular
that was well i mean
the first night you know like always
after i do play there'll be like you
know one guy who like kind of knows me
and he'll be like hey dave you were
great it was like right here you like
something like dennis o'hara
hey man i just want to say hi i was in
the audience and then um
and then the second night there was like
25 people like saturday night there was
like 20 people who just were like yeah
we were just like near the park and we
heard you're here and we just want to
say like stranger things is amazing
and the next night there was like 50
people and then my i mean i was like
this is a yeah it literally was an
exponential pandemic wow stranger things
was a pandemic wow
and uh it stayed on surfaces
so you knew that i mean everybody was
touching me with gloves
so that's when people approach you with
masks exactly
[Applause]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
the level of work that goes into
anything even stuff that sucks yeah yeah
is like so i have such respect for now
that i you know to my friends i can
i can trash stuff or whatever but like i
could never
i just am a lot more generous with
people just knowing that like you poured
i poured my heart into each thing yeah
it doesn't really matter i don't really
know it's like i'm pouring more of
myself into stranger things because you
love it yeah it's like i'm pouring just
as much into my flops you know well so
the the flop you're saying it was at
hellboy okay
most recently yeah i like that
how about well
because it didn't do it didn't perform
well or or the movie wasn't didn't
turn out the way i mean i think it was a
product of all of it yeah you know it
was a product of all of it yeah was it
something you saw coming were you like
oh or were you like oh yeah i mean it
was yeah you kind of know when you're
yeah yeah i mean although you don't
always know sometimes you cannot know
and there was a back and forth on that
where like at one point i was really
thinking it was really and then i saw a
cut of it and i was like oh they can
piece this together in some way and it
was kind of entertaining and i was like
and then um
and then it just you know everybody just
ganged up on it which i felt like was a
little bit unfair too it's not it is a
funny world we live in where
there are these you know superhero
movies like
like i thought thor ragnarok on rotten
tomatoes got 99 percent holy [ __ ] rotten
tomatoes
three percent higher than casablanca oh
yeah isn't that funny i know anyways the
future doesn't get a hundred percent
that yeah reviewing the l.a times oh
yeah and so that's the thing where it's
like and then this movie just got like i
forget what it was like eleven percent i
mean it's just so low but that
discrepancy where you're just like yeah
come on like come on like yeah we all
seem bad yeah it's like you know maybe a
c-minus but like yeah but but that is it
like it must be comforting knowing that
you
have this success to go back to and
knowing that there are hits and misses
and the fact that you're even like in a
weird way the fact that you're even
being targeted now you know well it's
like kind of cool i don't know that's
part of the thing it was like it was
also like
you know it it is the mark of uh my
friend was like it's the mark of a movie
started to start having flops yeah like
you can't yeah
you can't just have all winners need
haters like i need people who
brad pitt gets to work on the best
material he gets to choose from like the
cream of the crop and the fact that he's
still having fl i mean of course it's
like all of us yeah like
yeah so
there is
but and also it does ground you where
you just like oh yeah it's not like
and it is a really good thing where you
know you see it even with like baseball
players and stuff i used to i used to be
so
ungenerous where you'd be like you know
you just constantly be like oh man like
this season he sucks and this guy's
terrible
and you're like the level that they're
working at every day to like even have a
bad season
is
i know
it's like how can we even talk i know
judge these people i uh my brother and i
like to listen to to sports radio new
york especially new york sports
and these callers and you know they're
in there i mean i they're like cliche in
their mom's basements
and they're so ineffectual probably at
work and at home and they're probably
being brow beaten all day and they call
up and they got these opinions and
here's what i think aaron judge should
do to recap like what are you they're
talking about these like incredible like
you said these athletes that are at the
the their peak are at the human peak
yeah and they're judging them and
they're like here's what i would have
done but it's the same thing where i
felt like the target of
you know all of that rage because the
fanboy generation oh yeah has all of the
same ownership as you do of the yankees
yeah and if like well the yankees are
not using their pitching staff yeah like
you know correctly like those
things is not doing this or if the
hellboy is not doing that so what's the
prescription do you do you just stay
away from that do you engage at all i
mean you read those comments i go back
and forth you know i mean i do need a
certain healthy dose of self-hatred or
if you have this but like i crave it
sometimes well sometimes i like that i
want to hear someone call me a pizza me
too you know i don't
too many people no i know no please
well one every thousand but it is a
funny thing where it's almost like
gambling like yeah you know you don't
gamble to win like because if you keep
winning at the table like you just keep
playing until you hit that big really
some dose of reality and that's kind of
what i do with the comments is like i'll
go along and they'll be just thousands
of hearts and smiley faces like yes king
and then finally it's like
it's like
you're fat you're like like
you're the worst and you're just like oh
yeah so yeah i have some of that you
know i had um
because i used to actually gamble in
underground uh poker clubs in new york
um
like i was really into it like 50 like
rounders yeah holy [ __ ] like exactly
rounders the guys who wrote rounders i
played with the guy in the round is the
john malkovich guy
yeah with the orioles based on a real
guy
who's
fat and old and not intimidating like
john malkovich at all but like he's
there he loves kgb and he loves oreos
but uh
i would go gamble at these clubs
yeah i was doing a play i was doing
who's the favorite virginia wolf yes i
want to talk about that
okay okay
and i would go after the play at like 11
30. i'd go to these clubs and i'd play
until like six in the morning oh and i
would play with all my money from
virginia woolf which at the time
you know like i'm making a broadway
salary which is not bad it's not great
but it's like i would go with like 1000
bucks and i'd like
just like sometimes i'd win and i'd get
it up to like three four thousand
dollars by the end of the week and then
i would just take it like i was just
digging
and i remember wandering home at night
like after you take a hit after you lose
like 3 000 that you don't have yeah like
that month's rent yeah and walking home
just going like saying to myself just
going like have you had enough yet david
have you had another guy oh my god this
is weird
but the feeling was so uniquely
wonderfully horrible yeah like it's the
same thing when i scroll through those
comments where it's like a special brand
of self-hatred where it's like it taps
into something i am a beer [ __ ] like i
am a business i think we need some i
need some of that i don't know why did
you if
i was gonna ask you if his siblings how
many do you i do i have a i have a baby
sister yeah seven years younger and did
you was that from anything in childhood
do you need i wanted to know it was that
i mean it was definitely from my it was
definitely from parents
it wasn't my sister was lovely and my
sister
uh but it's definitely like you know i
come from a lot of the hopper stuff is
it's not based on
my mom and dad but it has a lot of these
elements like i was a southern texas
family like houston texas real good old
boys
like real heart like my grandma five
years old i got stung by a beam
i cried and she grabbed me and was like
boys do not cry don't you cry don't you
cry and i was like people like and
nowadays because we're so like sensitive
they're always like yeah well that's
horrible but it's like i kind of love it
there's a piece of me that just for
variety yeah like occasionally it's like
cool yeah that's cool that my grandma
did but it did it did um
it did have uh
you know some punishing shame oh [ __ ]
built into me like there's a there's uh
it is a keynote for hopper and it is a
keynote for me it's just these uh
you know
shame this
shame can also be a good thing yeah like
shame can make us
to pause there's some millennials that i
think maybe need a little more yeah i
mean that's the thing like shame can
actually give you a really grounded not
just millennials there's guys in their
50s yeah
there's guys who run the world who could
deal with a little more true i mean
there's i mean just that idea that like
you are just human and like you can make
mistakes like that you know were they uh
chris so christian a baptist
no it wasn't a religious based shame it
was more like around business oil yeah
like
cultural social
kind of were they large people yeah yeah
very large yeah the harvard my uh yeah
the or the riley that's the rank riley
all right all my my my mother's oh
really i can't do it yeah no you can't i
can't do it i defer to you
i went out with a girl a scottish girl
for for two years and i i
kind i can kind of do it i can't i can't
really i can't that's not bad there you
go a little bit haven't you had but you
oh you do a russian in in black widow
yeah but you probably have the
the the dialect coach oh yeah yeah you
must
no um
i did have a dialect coach for that it's
funny though i mean that whole thing is
an amalgam it's a strange thing because
like there are times in that movie where
the characters should be speaking
russian
yeah they're all russians like why even
have the accent but well this is the
this is the actual conundrum that i
couldn't i kept having discussions with
them about this and the marvel guys yeah
yeah coming out in may uh the marvel
hopefully dude
but
um
the uh the marvel guys would be like at
a certain point we're just like shut up
just do it i mean what are you talking
about it's not comic book but there was
this thing where it was like i remember
this very specifically hunt for red
october yeah amazing movie yeah
sean connery uh sam neil all these tim
curry all speaking in russian yeah and
then this guy sits down at a table
they're all speaking in residence this
guy sits down at a table the camera
zooms in on the book
as he's reading russian it stops
the guy starts speaking in english
and then they pull back and they're all
speaking in english and they're speaking
in their normal accents
so sean connery has a scottish accent
sam neil is kind of a an australian
accent yeah but they're not speaking
with russian accents because it
theoretically wouldn't make any sense
true to speak with a russian whereas you
there's some harrison ford movie u71 or
something about a u-boat yeah i remember
i came out when i was in college and i
was big intellectual and he had a
russian accent speaking english and i
was like that's absurd
so welcome to me in black widow oh
that's right but we did do some things
where we have flavor like occasionally i
will speak in russian yeah uh but it was
just this thing where it's like people
can't read subtitles that's so funny
that's so true i never thought about
that it's like you're right they would
just be speaking russian they would be
you'd be consistently speaking right and
so we don't have so i would just speak
in an american accent yeah because we
theoretically would be in the world of
raj just don't know it has an accent
right it'd be dubbed uh right but it
doesn't you know you can't do a movie
you can't you can't make it a foreign
film you can't make black widow like a
subtitle like whenever this character
speaks i mean marvel's big and they
they're resilient i'm sure yeah but it
gets a little you know but also as an
actor must've been cool to do to get to
do for the character that kind of it's
amazing yeah it's such a fun character
too
they haven't uh
he's still like big and hairy like he's
like
he's something he's also a maniac yeah
like wow he's a complete maniac and we i
guess when you're in it i don't know if
you have this experience but when you're
in it like i didn't even know
like because i'm just so kind of like in
it just kind of living it and i remember
occasionally kate the director would be
after it takes she'd be like oh my god
you're such a maniac
seem normal to me what are you talking
about like what does this mean we're
like
there was something where i'm like in a
mirror and i was like
i'm like posing like thinking i'm i'm
amazing
and she came over to me after she was
like oh wow that was so pathetic and i
was like i don't think you saw i don't
think you saw what it was it was
beautiful that's really cool
well that's the guy i mean whatever
you're tapping into is probably the same
sort of rage as you're walking home from
the poker game you know kicking yourself
or like scrolling through the comments
that's
really like
mining all that stuff it's great yeah
exactly i mean that's the best stuff
right when you're like super personal
about
what you can bring to a character yeah
that's the type of work that i'm always
trying to do is like just really
personal where like you watch it and you
wonder like
oh like yeah you shouldn't be doing that
yeah it's great i couldn't be doing that
i love that reaction that that you think
you're you're like really
you're posing in this way and you're
cool whether it's your cooler you look
powerful and the reaction i mean the the
scene through the a normal lens is like
oh that's pathetic it's really great no
it's amazing i don't think it's funny
because that stuff i don't think that
made it into the movie like there's
there are sequences that couldn't really
have you seen the final i'm gonna go see
it uh this weekend i'll go out to ellen
screen it but i i did some adr and i
don't think i think they had to scale it
back a little bit but there was this big
because this was the scene the amazing
thing about this movie we just improv
the hell out no kidding and and so this
scene wasn't even written we shot all
this crazy improv stuff we threw out
yeah and that was what was so fun
because one thing i can do like you know
i brought in all this stuff it's but i
brought all this stuff about communism
yeah and about just like
i mean it's uh yeah you're reading like
karl marx since you were yeah and i was
reading uh you know yeah i was reading
and you know there's like six stages of
communism like there's like the vanguard
party and the dissolution of the state
and like all these different things and
it's his particular take on all these
things which is he's not the sharpest
tool in the show
but he does try to read this stuff and
takes it seriously yeah and like his
beliefs about because one of the other
cool things about the russian culture is
like
the idea of
embracing communism like there's a
certain type of person a certain type of
culture
that like
i think has just decent good-hearted
like optimus or something i think
there's an optimism to communism yeah i
don't think yeah it works but it but
there's a there's a sort of like naive
like lovely quality that you see in like
chekov and and
tolstoy like these people that have big
hearts and like want to help their
comrades yeah there's a humanist element
to communism that i think gets
overlooked and uh
i hope there aren't sound bites now
being called from
either but you'd have more to lose like
a communist party yeah it's a movie
no but i know what you mean there's a
and certainly with the character like
that you
you have to find the beauty in it you
have to find the appeal and and you know
his take doesn't have to be the most
sophisticated yeah like he could have
bought into the propaganda like he can
just be a product of the propaganda
because natasha uh scarlett's character
is comes from a russian family right is
that what it is
that's unclear
yeah that's the marvel knee kept
breaking details that we can't really
get into but scarlett johansson is in it
okay
appears in the film and she is the black
widow but there is a family dynamic of
like she has a sister played by florence
pugh oh yeah amazing actress yes yeah
and then you know there is sort of a
matriarchal figure in rachel vice and
there is a patriarchal figure in in
the red guardian alexis shostakov
because there's one scene in the trailer
where it looks like you're all at dinner
together correct can i say this yes do
you have dinner in the movie or are we
allowed to say that yes i mean there is
uh and there and we play on the tropes
of those families
and that's what's really fun about the
movie yeah it's a kick-ass movie about
all these particular things and yet
there is these tropes of
yeah
like in the most recent trailer she's
like don't slouch and i'm like listen to
your mother like
you know there is this thing where it's
like yeah
right exactly well that's what's great
about stranger things too there are it's
really about for all these fantastical
things that are happening it's about
family and acceptance and it's about
these very uh relatable
things um
working in a russian gulag
um
you know
exactly
these themes seem to run through every
person yes uh how did you lose the
weight it's i'm just really shocking to
me the truth uh
it was intermittent fasting
and then uh pilates oh yeah yeah you
know they wanted him to be big and i was
big from the show and i was like all
right like no portion control and i
showed up on the movie and i was 270
pounds oh my so like when the movie
starts
but it's amazing bigger than lauren's
because like yeah like but in the movie
i'm like tyson fury like that yeah but
that's a better reference
in the movie it's amazing because it's
like this i mean i'm like this this
rhinoceros yeah like
and but the problem was so i got there
and i started doing like boxing for all
these stunts like i had a month of
pre-production to get oh wow to work on
these stunts like the the action
is
crazy and and i'm not doing a lot of it
like i'm doing very little yeah even the
little that i'm doing is so hard a lot
of training you can't even believe it
wow so wow i'm doing um so i started
boxing with this guy
just to get in you know to know how to
do this stuff then you're probably
losing weight from that a little bit but
also i was in such pain
because my knees like the stuff i had to
do and my knees like carrying that
weight around like all this crazy stuff
that i started doing rehab
with uh
with this dave higgins guy with pilates
like pilates reformer stuff can do you
do a lot of rehab yeah like a lot of
like joint rehab uh-huh and then at a
certain point i get into an outfit where
i could lose
weight and it could not be seen as much
you're the new iron man because they you
heard it here
you are yeah you are replacing it
doesn't make any sense i don't know
uh but they would they would pad me and
as i would start to slim down
on that particular movie i lost
like we shot that movie for four months
and i think i lost 40 pounds as we were
shooting
oh man
and then i got back and for this new
seat because i had to lose it for season
four oh my god while i was shooting
season four starting in january oh my
god so yeah i finished that movie and i
started losing more and then i went even
more intense like after i saw you
because we pushed to february i went on
a real intense thing and i lost another
um because now i'm like
now i'm like 200 so i lost 70 pounds all
the time oh my god that's crazy yeah and
um
wow so yeah so how do you do that while
you're so it's basically like
intermittent fasting
do you know what that is no it's
basically skipping breakfast
like but yeah it's kind of starving
yourself wow i do this thing where for a
while
yeah now it's no sugar but in the
beginning losing 40 pounds i could eat
anything and if you do it in an
eight-hour window yeah so you do it like
noon to eight or like nine to five you
just eat that that's correct and then
you stop
i was eating pancakes all kinds of stuff
and i was like losing weight yeah
yeah it was weird
and then now in the intense now i will
get like more intense stuff yeah now
it's more like no sugar and a lot of
vegetables and stuff like that wow but
it's still this idea that you do like
six or eight hour windows of eating and
then occasionally you do this 24 hour
fast was was your was that with juice
with like cayenne no i just do nothing
nothing for 24 hours water and black
coffee oh my god yeah are you tough to
be around are you uh yeah yeah i'm
unpleasant
that sounds funny i'm very unpleasant
but with the coronavirus scared oh it's
great i could just sit in my apartment
stare at a wall
benefit what a great benefit was your
girlfriend uh
did she because she signed up for
a burlier figure she was sad
she's mad
it's funny like she's uh like no you
were a bear you were like oh he was
really into it and i was like yeah no
now i'm gonna shave all the hair off of
me like a dolphin my beard and i'm gonna
lose 70 pounds yeah it's quite
interesting she's dating a different guy
and i'm like don't you like it i can
like move around now and she's like
that's what i signed up for yeah that's
funny i mean she also is like you know
it is
it is annoying because
i will see one of the most attractive
things about me as a 270-pound male
was that women were like
awesome i'll never be the fat girlfriend
because anywhere we are yeah just be
like oh i'll look very small in
comparison and that honestly is somewhat
generous
i think it's a generous thing to do to
you for your relationship yeah you know
what i mean like you don't need women to
feel more self-conscious about their
bodies right yeah and so as you slim
down and get more and more into the
narcissism of this yeah they're like
really dead like now i'm gonna be on
this it's like no you don't have to
honey it's like [ __ ] you you know i i'm
the burly one there yeah
maybe i should grow a beard
um
it's really uh i saw her at the
i saw you guys both of the basketball
game and
it's funny you say that about her being
because i didn't know who you were
dating i didn't know that she's a fan
she's just a lily allen yeah very famous
thing um but i remember thinking like i
i was looking at her thinking like i
know her somehow and i couldn't place it
uh and i then i thought oh well maybe
he's just sitting next to
they don't really know each i i just
thought maybe she was you know because
it was like when we were making out and
stuff i didn't see that putting together
oh you didn't see that
i wasn't staring at you kissing
you were like i checked it he doesn't
know oh yes he does
let's hope wow if they just met that is
good for both of them
[Music]
i'm gonna offend so many people by
saying this but i have terrible taste of
music
i don't think you'd expect me to like
this it's like
it's like terrible i mean it's like
sarah mclaughlin and like you know i
mean it's like jewish i like jewels yeah
exactly that's what it is
but it's like an east village well i
know it's a i'm sorry jewel i love you
but i you know it's like i'm an east
village like i consider myself kind of a
hip like all my friend or like cbgb's
like the clash and like
and it's like here i am going like i
will
[Applause]
like 10 years ago or 12 years ago or
something
one of her songs like ldn came on i
remember looking at the album cover and
there's like a you know it's her on like
a bike yeah like i love that song and i
was like oh wow that's a cool looking
you know
lady yeah she like had like a yeah sort
of sounded like that in it yeah exactly
exactly
and she uh and then i hope i'm not
turning you on too much thinking about
it wow that's a great impression we got
this table in front of us thank goodness
um
oh yes
sorry i'm getting sweaty it's so funny
but yeah
so that but i i didn't really know her
when i met her like i i kind of
remembered that but i didn't really like
she's one of these stars where she's
really big in england yes but she's not
like as known in america yeah it's kind
of great yeah we know her music and
stuff but uh because she but england has
such a big paparazzi like yeah and that
that thing is
awful yeah it's awful and it's um but
it's but it's very specific to that
island exactly like it doesn't you know
it doesn't have the same resonance yeah
like we're like who are you running
around following like yeah it's not
nearly i think it's far more invasive
there i mean it can definitely be bad
here depending on
you know who you are where you are but
um
she must have i can't imagine
having to withstand that the way she
must have had to
had to and i've never seen anything like
that yeah they're awful i've never seen
yeah they're awful yeah um
oh wait i want to talk about the
rainmaker
uh no no i'm sorry the ring why the hell
well that was your first big job
yeah you want to know about that yeah
you want to know about the rainmaker
well you're 20 years old yeah okay right
no 20
24 i think so i come out of dartmouth
and i had a theater company yeah where
we wrote and directed our own plays and
like and john grisham was part of the
john grisham edward john guerrero we
were all wow
ragtag
and edward albee so it was an
existential thriller we were just too
external though no admiral in theater
company it was a huge failure and then
like
like
yeah but we came to new york and then we
tried to do plays and it was like a mess
and i was drinking and
and then i know that poker's later i uh
i got sober and then i started working
commercially and i worked in two venues
one was like i started doing soap operas
i did as a world turns oh yeah i did
understudied on broadway and various
things and one of them was rainmaker
yeah
i was studying okay so this is the funny
thing about that so it's roundabout
roundabouts a non-profit theater yeah
they could do commercial productions on
broadway
and they did this commercial production
where we were under studies but we also
moved the furniture between scenes
and we were known as cow hands or
something so we had costumes
and cowboy hats and there were eight of
us
and
when the lights would come down low we
would come out and like move the chairs
around for the next scene yeah and then
go off none of us ever got to perform as
understudies oh but it was like woody
harrelson but they gave us and i think
it was because we were so much cheaper
we were so much cheaper than stagehands
i think because they only had to pay us
250 bucks a week oh yeah non-equity
contract we all got a little dressing
room so they called you a part they gave
you a part and then but then not only
that the most embarrassing thing was
that at the end of the show there were
like there's like eight characters in
the show and it was like woody harrelson
jane atkinson uh john bedford lloyd
and they would and and you know like so
they ate character drama they do this
drama at the end blah blah the final
curtain like you know
give me my hundred dollars or whatever
right and then
and then lights would go down audience
would applaud and eight
dudes would come out
he was the first val
because here's the thing
if they called us actors they had to
give us a bow oh yeah yeah oh my
goodness so that was probably what he
got away with that was the way they got
away with us were people like being in
this way it was hilarious because we
wouldn't be so psyched they'd be like a
plotting and then we'd all come out and
they'd all go like they'd all slow down
we would have your account
yeah but they'd be like we're these
eight guys and
is this a joke that's right because then
they would separate and then woody
harrelson all that would god they're
like oh yeah
yeah
it was so funny it's really funny did
you ever go on did you ever perform you
were an understudy no no and i was so
angry about that
probably didn't help them just drinking
yeah exactly i mean there's nothing
yeah there's there's nothing harder than
watching someone mess up a performance
that you know you could be brilliant and
you've learned all the lines yeah you
just sit there between the scenes and
then you go and move their chair for
them i mean it's just like you're like
where do you want this oh yeah sorry
good luck kill it tonight
was your family excited that you were
even just that you were on broadway at
all that you were
okay
i mean i think they were like
you know they i think they got excited
when i got nominated for a tony which
was like when i was 30. i think that's
when they finally that was for virginia
woof correct that was like
2006 or something 2007. i think that's
when they finally were like oh okay
oh interesting but
do they have high expectations then for
you
yes but i think there's just unrealistic
expectations for people in entertainment
at all yeah like i was doing
i think i i'm doing like the second
season of stranger things then people
are like people from my extended family
are like you're gonna make it one day
we know you're gonna make it one day
that's nominated
i mean
and i'm on like the biggest show
i mean when it when does it get to be
enough when does it get to be enough are
they oh that's funny yeah also just
having gone to dartmouth what a great
school and
i mean that's something to be
yeah i mean that was you know that was a
product of my
environment more than anything else i
wanted to
i wanted to drop out of high school and
go become an actor in new york i want to
do that whole thing and and i grew up in
westchester and i grew up in a world
white plains acting was uh born and
white plains then we moved to town
called armonk but like
not not a not a world where you had
examples of working actors yeah it was
all lawyers doctors yeah you know
business people
executives uh so the idea of this was
hard to define as an actor
i mean the whole western crew unless
until you're on the cover of people
magazine yeah i don't think you've and i
haven't hit that yet so i think they're
still thinking that eventually one day i
would like your podcast to be the bench
this is what's gonna do it uh what's
funny about
that people magazine specifically and
talking about paparazzi and your
relationship now
there was a time
when i was dating drew barrymore we were
together and my parents i think the way
they measured that kind of success i
think in the town i grew up in which is
probably not dissimilar to westchester
in fairfield connecticut um
they were always so excited uh when
people from the at the supermarket would
run into them and say i saw your son on
that on the cover of a thing or in a
tablet and it was this is tabloid stuff
this is like yeah
this this is the result of me
um having to like evade with someone
that i really cared about
having to evade these guys who were
stalking her i mean that that's what it
boiled down to and it became a measure
of um how they saw success you know and
and i never knew what to do with that i
never knew i certainly never took it on
board i always found it to be
kind of disgusting but i had some of
that you know i dated julia stiles
yeah julie and i dated for like a year
and a half and
i wasn't recognizable in any way yeah
and um and i had the same thing from a
lot of westchester parents where they're
like oh
i mean one of the things that's so scary
to me about the algorithm that is uh
chasing through all of our lives
likes things
is that we are equating popularity with
good right and
they are not the same right that's the
illusion that social media
you can expose as much as you want
or as little as you want of yourself but
it's also to a certain degree i think
the anonymity like it's this idea that
and it's also this performative aspect
like
what i want with fans more of is
an
accountability like and it's part of the
reason why i kind of like those cons
you're actually meeting real people and
sometimes and most of the time they're
just lovely and they have the same
vulnerabilities that we're talking about
where they're like yeah i didn't like
your hellboy but i like you and i'm
sorry i didn't really like it or
or i did like it or whatever yeah it's
like yeah but it's a sweet interaction
as opposed to somebody just yelling like
peaborg number 84.
do you remember when when um
what was that thing it was it was uh
roulette chat room chat
yes i used to love chatroom did you do
it i didn't i did i never did it i was
terrified but i always wanted well is it
not around anymore i don't think i don't
think so but i remember a lot of the
people were they'd be
they clicked right off because they were
guys
yeah and it was just like dicks and it
was like nope and they'd all click off
uh but every once in a while you get
like a group of people just like hanging
out like hey what's up and they'd be
like
you know it was fun to get recognized in
that situation because they'd be like
hilarious you think are you the guy in
the thing and then if they got weird you
could just click them off and if they
were sweet you could kind of like talk
to them yeah that's cool oh my god i'm
gonna get my brother he left you that's
cool that's cool it was really fun there
was a guy who did it at his concerts it
was like ben or something he would like
be at a concert and they have the big
screen and he'd like play a song or
something oh that's cool
um
it is an interesting thing when you
mention hellboy and like i've done
my share of
movies where people are like oh they say
in a sweet way i hated you and i hated
this that you did this thing that you
worked on i know it's like
i can't believe or i can't believe you
did that or you know there was the
normally people don't like but it was
funny i was at this uh thing in this con
in liverpool and there was like all
these people who actually really loved
the movie there and there was one kid
who came up who clearly was um very on
the spectrum like very sort of autistic
and he was talking about like
surprisingly how he liked stranger
things and like then he was like uh i
did not care for hellboy but it was just
so it was just so like earnest yeah it
was just so what it was yeah i was like
yep all right can't argue with that all
right
you're here
i guess you just are you just have a
need to express your truth yeah right
now i didn't i didn't need it but thank
you but thank you okay um
uh these are yes some of those yeah
people can be very uh i think it's cool
though i mean i love i mean i myself
struggle with uh
what's classically deemed as mental
health issues yeah and i do love the um
at these cons that there does seem to be
just like a a room and a place for for
these people for all of us to not be
made fun of outsiders who are birds and
like and like you know i agree people in
in all sorts of mental states coming
together and us being like
yeah man like we love all this weird
stuff pretty [ __ ] i love it i know
that's why i like it and i don't think i
had that growing up i think i was just
like an outcast i think yeah like i was
a member of the uh like chess club the
chess club i remember that i belonged to
the
this is really going to reveal how cool
i was at the southern uh southern
connecticut herpetological society the
herps the herps i know all about the
herbs i used to raise the tree frogs no
kidding oh the hurt what kind of tree
frog
by the way they need to be rained on 18
hours a day for them to [ __ ] oh and they
need to have a foot of water in their
aquarium
so i built how you got the rain
aquariums yeah that were like six feet
tall they would have a foot and a half
of water with rain pipes and some pumps
again me in an apocalypse i know how to
build a wide street version
with some pumps so the water would
continue to rain on them
for 18 hours a day because their skin is
so they would well they just know that
their eggs will survive if the if the
rainy season is there oh my god and if
there's enough water they know that
they'll be able to lay or make them
tadpoles will
yeah and so they get really frisky
oh
you need to get like a female and a male
together and you when you rain on them
18 hours a day and then you got baby
frogs you have to fluff them in any way
they just get out
what got you into tree tree frog what
i've always been a frog guy yeah
i gotta say they are the silliest
creature imagine like your superpower
just being like
jumping yeah yeah like they could oh
they're just like
i mean i could jump like over a like i
could it would it would be like me
jumping over that building oh tree fries
i mean magic yeah
anyway so i so when i was like
five years old growing up in white
plains in the backyard of my little
house yeah there would be codes yeah
okay
and i would catch them and at one point
i had an aquarium filled with 36 toads
me too they were i'm [ __ ] did you really
yes so connecticut yeah connecticut
white plains all you do is like catch
toads and you're like middle class like
like lower middle class yeah and i had
like but my parents would still let me
like my our bottom back we had a bathtub
in our bottom floor uh bathroom and at a
certain point they just let me have
turtles in there and yeah
wait i had a turtle barney the box
turtle who would just wander around the
house oh i had victor i'd victory and i
and then i found out it was bad to have
them on the floor no
yes that's how he died and i was like
he's such a good boy he's always just in
the one corner he knows not to leave
that corner and then i found out hold up
sick i got the best story so barney was
a boxer you just go around and then we
put him out on the porch screened in
porch okay put him on the screen in
porch at night
and uh we just feed him cantaloupe
during the day but what happened is
cantaloupe i don't know he loved kellogg
he would he would come alive
but anyway he
there'd be holes a little bit in the
screen imports and raccoons would come
in yeah
so we would fight but but box turtles
can completely box themselves up there
so another
one right yeah so they completely yeah
so these we would find him after a night
we would find him
shoved in the corner of the screened in
porch with scratches all over him
and he had just been battered around by
these dragons all night like we got to
get that thing out of there and he was
like nope he's like everybody
out a forgot
cantaloupe and he'd be like hey guys is
it okay how do you go out again
so anyway i had so yeah i had barney the
box turtle i had and then i had 36 toads
and i would play with these toads i
can't believe you remember the number
and uh yeah because i remember that was
a big thing because they were like on
top of each other there were so many of
them on the spectrum and get yeah
totally we'd get like um crickets from
the pet store yeah lifeguards 100 of
them yeah and we pour them in there and
they'd be gone in seconds yeah yeah so i
like loved frogs and toads it's funny
and i'd grow up just catching them all
the time that's so crazy so when i was
an adult
in
in the east village i had like i have
like a little apartment like a studio
apartment doing virginia woolf
edward albee like
i would tell him about the toads oh the
frog frog all the time he
loved he just all he wanted to do was
talk to me about frogs it's fascinating
but he's into it
oh he just loved it about me yeah that's
all he like yeah i love that but i was
building my own aquariums like custom
aquariums with
this plexi that i get at canal plastics
actually i'd get like i designed these
aquariums this is for the white's tree
frogs yes i would design these like
elaborate
like six foot tall terrariums with
terrariums with um
sections of water and then sections of
like with the sump pump and these rain
pvc pipe
and it took up like half the apartment
and i had like
five or six white street frogs
and i would uh i would try to get them
to breed like that was my big thing
because i had a cat and i had these tree
frogs
and i just love them i just love frogs
it was something about like i guess at
that point in my life it was something
about
getting back to
a childhood theory it's just something
that i loved so purely absolutely that
had nothing to do with anybody else yeah
it was just like a pure expression of
something that brought me like joy and i
just watched these little dudes and they
just would sit on the glass all day long
oh they're they're really cool too just
they're just beautiful they got those
big brows that like come over there and
they're like blue green sharpies exactly
yeah and they and then at night
they come alive like they just sit there
like zen masters all day
no they're very quiet they're very quiet
huh yeah they will come alive but they
do have lots of uh
you have to clean out they poo a lot oh
really a lot of poop and like big long
oh yeah i got tired of that like every
day there seems to be like a couple well
because one of my favorite sounds i
remember being on vacation in puerto
rico and there's a cokey frog there
there's oh they do have those
they all have such different beautiful
sounds but where i live in massachusetts
uh one of my favorite sounds in the
world as when the spring peepers come
out um oh yeah and they mate in the
vernal ponds there i i just love that
sound that sound of summer and the
cicadas um
what is your most uh commonly used emoji
would you say
oh um that's a really good one
i did have the rolly eyes one a lot yeah
and then i also had like i didn't
realize it was really eyes
it's like oh yeah yeah and then there's
the one with the tongue out and the
little oh yeah this one
i'm
the
messing around
yeah that's a good one uh if you could
be a professional athlete what sport
would you play boxing oh yeah that would
be a boxer you enjoy it you watch them
love it oh really oh i love you you know
rockwell are you you you're friends uh
yeah
yeah yeah
he loves it as well you guys should
watch him uh yeah i love it so much um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life
what would it be oh god that's a good
question
i mean i guess like just a big old box
of honey nut cheerios
and just no i don't know i just said
that just handfuls yeah oh yeah oh yeah
yeah that reminds me i could rock that
at like three in the morning yeah after
a nice intermittent fast just
[Music]
24 hours of black coffee and water um
what's your favorite movie of all time
that's so hard i hate that question i
think that's such a stupid [ __ ]
question i'm sorry i don't know it's
like it's like what's your favor i mean
that's no because movie lovers uh shame
me for that all the time yeah because
there's so many i mean like like off the
top of my head whenever anyone asks us i
don't think it's my favorite movie at
all yeah but it's my subconscious
i hate it
the matrix oh
which is like not that it's my favorite
movie but i just think it's so watchable
that yes it's just so watchable i guess
that's a better
way that's a better way to phrase that
question like i could just put it on
right right whereas like my favorite
movie might be like the shining yeah but
like i don't know i mean every time
every time i think about turning it on
i'm like
i know i know i was like this like
florence just had a movie where it was
like
i thought it was a terrific movie that i
never want to watch again that midsomer
movie oh i
was like that is a terrific movie that i
never want to watch again ever ever ever
ever ever i knew it would be like that
and i loved that guy ari asterisk god
that movie scary i i i loved that guy's
movie that he did before hereditary it's
have you seen her no i hear that's
really good it's so good and i sound
like three times in the theater so i oh
so you will watch mid-summer over and
over again then because i was like i do
not want to feel these feelings that i'm
feeling right yeah yeah he's such a good
director uh
it's a gaslighting movie i think
actually yeah i think it's a movie about
being gaslit but it's a horror movie i
mean so i i did a podcast with that guy
and i was like i went on about what a
fan i was and he was like and then
mid-summer came up and they're like what
do you think of the summer and i was
like i haven't seen it and it had been
out for like six months amazing a huge
fan yeah um yeah i i need to see that i
was like that with marriage story
everyone was like he got and i knew i
loved noah bomback and i was like i
gotta see it and i saw it oh it's what
you think it's great but it's also yeah
very depressing yeah um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met they're alive they could be alive
yeah well you're having dinner so even
if they're dead
yeah god
and then again it does take into
question the authorship question but
whoever wrote shakespeare plays
that guy william shakespeare it was like
that's right i'm sort of a feel you know
i believe that it wasn't the actual dude
william shakespeare wrote those plays
but oh that's a whole nother boring poem
talking about a podcast that'll put you
to sleep david harvard straight for
three hours about the authorship
question the stranger things fans are
gonna love this
was it um who who was the one in
question it was uh
ma
what's his name oh marlo marlo joseph uh
yeah he is the theory yeah yeah but
there's people sort of in elizabeth's
court i was like uh rupert everett wrote
that
i was thinking about the shakespeare
exactly rupert everett
yeah um
but uh
i would i would sit down with
yeah
that person is uh you think was written
by one beautiful i do yeah oh and and
william shakespeare just took the credit
well i actually think that like because
the thing about writing at that time or
at least writing plays is it was sort of
thought of as if um i'm trying to think
of what it would be thought of as now
but like it was kind of taboo it was
like doing porn or something i mean it
was not yeah it was kind of like that it
was like jeremy of that time was
yeah it was looked at as disgusting so i
think what these guys in court like they
just had this they wanted to write these
plays but they would just give them to a
guy who was like their fig you they're
kind of like
just say like you can well you can make
kind of a living as a playwright so this
guy was just kind of a dumb dude who
lived in stratford and
and they were like you should write that
movie
yeah
yeah but it shouldn't be
yeah yeah okay should write a sonnet
about that uh
that's kind of a great idea for a movie
i think they've done it but it's
terrible it didn't do but it's it's the
authorship but you're right it should be
presented in a way that makes it
entertaining i do think it's in the how
yeah um but yeah so that that person i
would definitely
uh want
to
sit down with
um
who else
um
i got two more
oh god i got two more yeah
um
this might be a little easier yeah give
me some easier i mean who's your
favorite muppet
oh uh who do you identify with the most
probably miss piggy oh yeah
you want to be
show business i mean she's a star
you know what i mean when you said that
like she loves kermi but she knows it's
about her you were sort of
not stroking but kind of like massaging
your chest a little bit
the way you said it
um
yeah i can see that's funny uh and you
yeah you got sort of koi uh
uh where if you could live somewhere
else where would it be
if you had your druthers um
i'd like to live in uh i'd like to live
in india i'd like to live in the north
of india oh wow or maybe in mumbai but i
i mean i would actually yeah i actually
might live in i might actually give it
all up and move to i mean have you ever
been to india
it is
it is like
being in an alien it's like being on
mars wow but like
it's the coolest but you're able to
breathe
yeah yeah but yeah but no it's just that
people view life differently yeah it's
like everywhere else i've been even like
in bulgaria or lithuania or
you know atlanta uh or like south
america all these different places
there's this
there's this kind of structure to life
and then you go to india and it's like
the values are different wow like people
just value different things and you feel
so
i feel so um like alive oh wow um i you
made me want to go uh if you could have
one superpower what would it be
invisibility easy
it's the only one yeah it's like who
cares flying yeah please whatever
beams come out of your eyes yeah
yeah okay invisibility at will you could
go
just be invisible get on a private jet
and like exactly
and then just you'd have to sit on
somebody's lap or you just walk into a
bank and get so much money and buy the
whole jet you know that's true well you
really can't you really thought about it
it's okay no the invisibility i feel
like this is as dumb a question as
what's your favorite movie um no if you
have to be one age for the rest of your
life physically what would you pick
physically just physically yeah you
remembered feeling like oh this is it
oh god physically but just physically my
brain could still be your brain is what
it is now oh wow yeah oh probably like
24. yeah right
yeah i mean that's right
sorry like it's nice
like who's like 65. my peak wasn't
necessarily 24 i mean like you know you
you may have what were you like 11 my
peak my p was three
yeah that's when i was at my best um
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would it be
i mean a bear no
white streak oh
it's only been 17 hours but i'm starting
to feel it i'm starting to feel it get
over here come here
the moisture is doing its thing
uh would you rather be called on a train
on you know on a
instagram uh yeah you're reading
comments somebody says
he's unattractive
or ugly or unfunny what would you what
would you prefer
god that's hard yeah
wow that's hard it's tough i uh i mean i
think i just want to be attractive
yeah i don't know that i care about
funny oh really i probably care more
about attractive okay i probably care
more about attractive would you consider
yourself a trap were you considered
attractive when you were in high school
not really no okay well then maybe that
that's the reason yeah
that's the reason because so many i can
so many people now would probably be
what about you uh
i wasn't considered attractive in high
school but i didn't think of myself
still want to be you put your pride more
in funny than attracted i think so i
think i value it more and if somebody
said
but here's the flip side to that if
somebody said oh he's not funny i i
would consider their take i wouldn't
consider their taste uh as valuable i
wouldn't consider i wouldn't give them
as much value their taste because even
if it was like larry david oh if it was
larry david heartbreak i mean it was
bill murray
yeah
they could say he's the ugliest human
being i've ever met but he's really
funny
right
thank god yeah he looks like a monster
but he made me yeah larry davidson i'm
gonna change my answer yeah think about
that
you're right though if it's a troll you
don't want to be thought of as unfunny
like they're all going to call you
unattractive anyway exactly
you're right you're right i'm with you
on this um change my answer uh which
golden girl do you most identify with
dorothy blanche rose or sophia um i
think uh b arthur yeah that's which one
is that dorothy yeah yeah the one who's
like laying down the law and like
talking about all these crazy ladies
running around
like rolling her eyes like that that's
why you like rolling the eyes exactly
like i can't deal with these golden
girls anymore yeah uh uh dogs are cats
oh
oh god this has changed but no it's dogs
it was cats for like
for like 30 years oh wow and recently
now it's done got attacked by a cat
no it wasn't the cats went down the dogs
eclipsed um i fell in love with the dog
one in particular yeah i fell in love
one sort of turned me on and now i'm
kind of in love with a lot of dogs i was
really resentful of dogs for a while why
i really didn't like them i didn't like
the ownership like
i was one of those guys and i had this
when i had it done i was walking along
and there'd be people who were this like
because you know you walk the dog yeah
somebody's on the sidewalk and
somebody's dog is like way out in the
thing in new york and you're like dude
can you get your dog like i'm tripping
on you you i'm gonna kick your stupid
pug if you don't like take well there's
no consideration for the amount of the
width of the sidewall sidewalk yes yeah
and so i was one of those guys who was
like you and your entitled dog owners
and now the same thing will happen to be
going look at this yeah that's nice
um
uh and do you ever think about
you didn't grow you said you weren't
raised in a religious family uh do you
think about the afterlife your show
deals with this other world do you ever
think about what maybe beyonce
um
is a terrible question for the lightning
round yeah yeah i mean it's really
i i do have very
complicated
ideas about it because i have have you
ever fainted i don't recall fainting i'm
sure i have i've had like blackout
periods oh really of like um
re-entering
my body or whatever and not knowing my
name oh really yeah
or like even that i was a human being at
first like kidding yeah like you were
completely new uh well just that it's
very disconcerting like like i've
fainted when i have like some blood
drawn some of this stuff and it's
literally you're out for a couple
seconds but i come this rush thing comes
back where you're like
just everything's like colors and shapes
and then you start to realize they're
humans but i don't realize that i'm a
human then i'm like oh i am a human i'm
david i'm david harper okay and then oh
my god so
in that way in the blackout period it
feels somewhat like death to me where
it's like
huh i do think the only experience we
can actually count on ever is waking up
right yeah the only thing that you'll
you'll be sure of is that you'll wake up
so if there is no waking up
i don't think anything exists
i don't think there's like like the real
problems i have with heaven
because like my mom died fairly recently
and i said yeah and there were some
people who were um
was she religious
no
uh
but there were some people who were very
like you know
um
oh she's up there in heaven in a better
place and i was like
no i mean she may be she's she was out
of pain and there was a lot of great
things about it to be honest but
this idea that she was in heaven always
struck me when people said that to me i
was like what age is she
and like
what age is she she's in heaven what
does her what she look like yeah what's
she look like yeah is she what's she
doing is she yourself like without
arthritis or right does she have
arthritis in heaven or right is she
allowed to smoke does she watch her does
she have a cough yeah i was like it
doesn't make any sense right like it
just doesn't
the idea that we
were she scared about that before um
i don't think so
no it was uh
no
it was um
[Music]
i don't think she was a
i don't think she was afraid she had
some cancer earlier the cancer wasn't
what killed her but um
she had cancer earlier and she said
after she got through that that she
sort of cured her fears of death wow i
don't particularly have that much
fear of death itself i have much more
fears of um
of uh pain uh-huh you know your cultural
pain yeah but the the idea of death like
i you know i think i'm good like i i
would want to i you know of course i
want to live for various experiences but
also to foster other people in various
experiences like i think i've
you know to help like i wouldn't want
for my girlfriend or people that love me
to die in a sense but i
i don't have that much fear of going
myself that's great well you're very
lucky well
you have to go now yeah there we go
sorry uh but i i i
i i can't thank you enough for doing
this this is really fun thanks for
saying you've always been somebody that
i've really admired and it's nice to to
have some time to sit down with you oh
thanks bob well i've always loved you as
well
[Music]
so that happened
so that happened was that like an
ominous stranger things
i don't know maybe
i never know how to do that i i want to
do it a different way i know and at this
point it's just like
it's gone past the point of us making
fun of it and being ironic about it but
it's it's it's never passed way fast
like episode three yeah uh but it that
happened and uh
i really enjoyed him i had run into him
a couple of months earlier did we talk
about that at um
this this nrdc charity event no i think
you alluded to it you alluded to seeing
him at the basketball game that we were
at yeah we were both there remember he
was sitting a couple of seats and we
were like uh
kind of giddy like eavesdropping we were
like snooping on him yeah it was so
embarrassing i basically admitted that i
was like i noticed you sitting next to a
gal a gal pal
uh but he we were like dishing dirt
about them
oh we weren't i knew i recognized her
she's the the singer lily allen
you guys talked in the beginning about
covid and how
he's not
scared of it you're very cavalier and
you didn't think it was going to develop
into much and now it feels in retrospect
that
conversation not only feels wrong but it
feels a little insensitive but uh i know
it shouldn't because
things hadn't materialized yeah it must
sound so dated it sounds so glib you
were like i don't think anything's
happening really yeah wow they're like
look what happened with uh h1n1 all
right stars and they came and went and
that was zika that was like three weeks
ago yeah wow things change yeah they
sure have um well
yeah he he was also flying a lot as i
recall
yeah and he didn't seem concerned about
i i wasn't i more concerned than he was
though about it
you were but not much really it didn't
didn't come off that way maybe i was
trying to sound cool i remember being
nervous when on my that last day in new
york to the point where i rented a car
instead of taking the train back do you
have a picture of yourself after getting
[ __ ] by that bird
yeah you do yeah i post i think i put it
on instagram i'll put it on i'd like to
see that oh it's i haven't shown you no
i didn't show you i don't think so oh my
god it was crazy i took a bunch of i
didn't i never really captured the
extent of the damage
of the deluge it was like um i mean it
wasn't like you know
it was by far the most i'd ever i was
just going to say well
[Music]
it was it was crazy but it felt like
near your face um it got near it it got
it was
all down my it looked like somebody
cracked a white egg on my head gross it
was gross it was like all it was like
smeared down my hair and all over my um
but it was funny i don't know if i
articulated this properly uh but i had
been weirdly aware of what i was wearing
like
like uncharacteristically like aware of
the shirt i was wearing i and it was
like a nice shirts and i never think
that about um
and and i i put it on like feeling good
about myself and
and i was headed back to get a pair of
something gloves or something
and it was like somebody
poured a cup of something on me that's
that's what it felt like the volume of
it felt you're lucky it didn't go in
your mouth i know i know if i had been
looking up at all sometimes i ten
sometimes i do look up i would wonder
yeah i kind of do i i often have those
moments like in american beauty where
he's like whoa they're looking at the
bag oh my god i i obviously don't want a
bird to [ __ ] in your mouth but the
thought just the uh
the footage of that oh i can't
oh it might be worth it priceless i
don't want that to happen either but i
had a friend in middle school whose mom
was at a baseball game and she oh
doing a version of that looking up in
wonder
and a bird pooped in her mouth and
according to him i wasn't there but
according to him it was like
within seconds
after she spit it out of course and
rinsed her mouth out and within seconds
it was it was like
all these little spots oh my god
developed in her mouth and down her
throat no
poop is oh i don't think he gets any
poop is toxic but but bur specifically
like seagull oh really
garbage
all right it's so toxic you think it's
more toxic than other poops i i would
guess yeah i've been watching a lot of
impractical jokers and which i can't
recommend enough the show on true tv
um i got i'd love to talk to those guys
on the show sal volcano and those guys
but um there was one episode where sal i
think has to go through a mound of
elephant
poo
to find its keys remember that that was
awful it was but i remember thinking
i would for whatever reason and and i
think i know the reason actually i would
much rather go through elephant elephant
poop to get to my keys than like dog
poop
certainly that human has because because
elephant poop is like it's like hey yeah
yeah like horse poop it's like yeah it's
it's mostly hay yeah yeah i wouldn't
want to do it it's very fibrous but
here's the thing if i was going to do it
now's the time because i can't smell oh
that's right christian
due to his
covid has lost the sense of god we
haven't really talked about that
there's not much to say about it well
there is i mean
you are you love food and and i can you
know what's interesting are you scared
that it's not going to come back uh you
keep asking me that and i keep saying no
but that sounds thanks for planting the
seeds
i don't come back uh it's very strange
because i
you you just learn to appreciate what
tastes is more because
now i can't like for instance i'll have
a piece of pineapple and my tongue
will know that there's something sweet
in my mouth i can i can like feel
feel sweetness
but i can't pinpoint
uh the the pineapple weird weird whereas
it's like if you have a cold if you came
with something uh salty like yeah it's
different than when you're when you have
a cold so you have a cold and you're all
stuffed up you can't taste anything and
you're just all blocked up but this is
weird because my mouth recognizes
certain
types of food yeah but it can't pinpoint
specific flavor what was your experience
last night i made a uh like a
cauliflower curry um lentil thing but
there was there was
cumin or cumin do you say cumin i say
cumin
isn't it cumin tomato tomato oh really i
think so
human human human human
um
what was your experience like tasting
that
uh could you taste it at all because as
i was cooking i remember thinking like i
might as well just be making i should be
having like
my taste may be coming back slightly
because it's i taste very vague the
first day or two of it i really tasted
nothing weird and now i feel like i
taste a little bit more you know i was
texting with a friend last night who
also has a mild case of covet and uh she
said the same thing it cannot taste it's
very strange smell i wonder how many i
wonder how many people listening have
that experience anyway um
uh back to poo
you guys were talking about the wait
hold on wait you know what it reminded
me of really quick while we're on this
scatological subject is um
did we ever talk about this when
jonah i think it was schmidt's mother
jonah's friend schmidt i think i may be
misquoting him uh
she walked somebody farted it may have
been schmidt
and his mother
walked into the room
took
one
breath and threw up and threw up
immediately
do you think that's a true story i don't
know i doesn't sound true she threw up
in the sink she was like making her way
to the sink already
sick or something right anyway it was a
funny it's funny to imagine
he thinks he was talking about the
climate change
zombie apocalypse that's going to happen
in 10 years and
oh yeah and how actors are going to be
irrelevant yeah actors and influencers
and i think he's right and i think even
what we're seeing
now with what's happening with this
covid i know you see
how actors are
becoming relevant just the just how much
that uh imagine video backfiring i don't
know it's almost like people are like
shut up i know and let's you know praise
the doctors for a while yeah it's not
about you um but then he he went on to
say that
he uh in in such an apocalypse he would
be worthless because he has no skills
and
uh but then he quickly
reverses no
i can like
rebuild car engines
survival skills but by that point you
had already said bear grylls you were
like all my skills come from boy scouts
and he's like oh really well i can
actually do all this stuff
oh i would definitely want him on my
side yeah he seems like it yeah i don't
know why he was uh he's like a
survivalist he's and he's he looks like
a big
it was it surprised me when he said he
had didn't have those skills and then i
thought oh i'm just um i'm stereotyping
him because of the way he looks and and
i guess the roles he's played he seems
like he'd be this he looks like a
survivalist yeah this this responsible
um can do kind of person he's also very
intelligent yeah he really is dartmouth
right dartmouth um you know you're just
saying something about this time and and
the effect that it's having the
collective human effect that it has and
uh
i want you to read drew barrymore wrote
this article for refinery 2029 is that
it um
and she said something really
interesting in a bunch it was a really
great article but she said um
and i really like the way she phrases
she go to the great equalizer
that's what this is we're all
experiencing the same thing and people
with money people with fame and status
whatever it it it doesn't um it doesn't
really change this the effect that it's
having i mean it does to the extent that
like some of us the more privileged
healthcare or better healthcare can stay
inside it's revealing all of those
unjust um discrepancies i guess yeah but
she also said something i i keep
thinking about which is um
she said i hope that people don't indul
she said it more eloquently than i will
but i hope they don't indulge in when
this is over they don't indulge in in a
return to normalcy you know like do all
the because there is something about
the resetting effect that this is having
on the earth and on all of us
it would be nice to learn some lessons
yeah as a people
um you asked
if uh
if the stranger thinks kids had changed
and and and he didn't say no and there
was a a moment of silence i didn't pause
and i uh
i thought it was very funny yes
was screaming at me yeah well i mean
of course i mean that's
inevitable like that's inevitable and
you you there's this there's this like
tidal wave of fame and st your status is
social status is elevated and
adults can't handle that
it must have been it must be really
difficult to i mean not difficult but
difficult to manage yeah difficult in a
sense and psychologically difficult yeah
you guys were talking about uh
about communism and you were
trumpeting the uh i don't know the
positive aspects of
communism and i thought it would be so
funny
if a story came out that you guys were
communist
like during this cobit scare there was
like a little
red star pop-up
because of this podcast if ever there
was a time to have a scandal you know
like that it would be a funny story it'd
be a funny scandal
have you heard that justin long's a
communist
well it's like those things pop up with
with really famous people like you were
telling me about the tom hanks one where
there was this conspiracy theory that
tom hanks was
you know i don't want to say it i don't
want to give any like fuel to it but
it's just like ridiculous uh kind of
like pizzagate type stuff it's the same
organization oh it was oh my god
he has a real
uh self-hatred streak that he talked
about yes it was very interesting yeah
gambling i'm surprised he was very
honest about it and they're very honest
and reading the bad comments yeah but
you see i'm glad you asked about his
childhood because
you see her
he said he told a story about getting
stung by bee and how and
grandmother don't boys don't cry yes but
shame gets built in that it's amazing
how that affects your entire life when
something like that happens as a kid i
was i was just for some reason watching
that clip from the big lebowski when he
says
real men also cry yeah are you surprised
by my tears mr lebowski yeah
yeah
it reminds you of that yeah yeah sorry
uh i couldn't believe i couldn't believe
how similarly nerdy you guys are
i know i'm surprised that it took like
an hour into the interview where you got
you realized this amazing connection you
had about
frogs
isn't that crazy so excited oh i was
surprised because also i mean again
judging a book by its cover he just
seems like such a strapping outdoorsy
sturdy guy who would never
be to me like
but then frogs is like an outdoorsy kind
of thing if you're into frogs but he's
like a collector he's like he's at a
whole other level i'm i like frogs a lot
still i love the sound of frogs i was
taking a walk yesterday and you did say
you like spring peepers and i hadn't
heard that you said that and now it
sounds like i stole your
answer from the other day oh yeah when i
said that i like spring peepers i had no
idea you had said that huh
huh but now i feel like i see it yeah
it's gonna sound like that maybe i was
very
honest that he admitted that he um when
he was talking about
uh would he rather be
called unattractive or unfunny
and i i really respected the fact that
he was like i i want people to
think i'm good-looking yeah
yeah it's hard to admit that it is it is
and it may have to do with again i'm
sure it has everything to do with his
how he was as a child as a kid you know
maybe he wasn't or didn't think of
himself as like a good-looking guy as a
good-looking kid you know and
yeah that was
that was really honest of him he's a
dorothy that he and he and he knows it
and i feel like the real dorothy is like
me
and david harper
uh never think you would say that
sentence
i wonder if anyone's ever
said that sentence about themselves real
dorothy is like me and david maybe
someone named dorothy has said that
what also sounds a little bit like when
i think of dorothy
oh i was thinking clueless oh clueless
wait there's like a pejorative term for
uh
being sexual is that what that means i
think so i think so
oh yes um
i really i i are you sure you're not
thinking of another oh maybe you're
right i might be wrong i'm a
dandy no i think it's dorothy oh god
hold on wait can you pause this video no
i just want to check no
i also want to check out who played the
big lebowskis is killing me that i don't
know no one cares i think people are and
if people care they can easily google it
right now that's true
i'm mad at myself about you yes yes
psychologically this is it's weird i
have that in me where i have to
know that i'm right or something it's
what is that
um ego is that just i don't want to say
no what what is it i know i'm saying i
don't want to speculate because i don't
i don't know
it's it's i it's hard for me to stop
thinking about it
it's obsessive
well it's obsessive yeah [ __ ] all right
i'm like he's dorothy i'm a dorothy you
can watch me evolve you can hear listen
to me evolve i'm letting it go so i
don't know who played the big lebowski
hey let's read a letter okay
okay
it's not charles turning it he reminds
me of charles turner charles bronson
yeah mr charles brown thank you charles
carl
thank you charles barkley narl sparkly
um okay
i can't believe there was a song a
mainstream song called [ __ ] you it was
forget you in the mainstream mainstream
no it was
wasn't it [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you too how does it go not that not
like that
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you and the [ __ ] you too i and i'm
also trying to think that lily out still
got all these songs all these things
swimming in my little in the dudes
little noggin
the duder okay
i almost had it okay
hi long brothers hope you and your loved
ones are doing well i just started
listening to your show this past month
and it's been wonderful
i love how you speak seamlessly
of farts and death
thank you
not at the same time keeping it light
but keeping it real and deep at the same
time i really enjoy the sibling talk
especially with amy
as i'm the middle of uh amy sedaris as
i'm the middle of a pack of five wow my
sister and brothers are all in central
california and i'm fifth wheeling with
spanish and catalan flatmates in the
center of barcelona
well spain was very hard-hit by chris
barthelona sorry barcelona two of my
housemates work in separate hospitals so
we're constantly receiving updates from
the front lines
we're also practicing social distancing
within our own apartment as one flatmate
is working around patients with a virus
and the other is in the nicu
here we're only supposed to go out for
food or medicine or work if it's
essential and the police have started
ticketing people who are just out
walking around wow god
we've been making a list for groceries
and only send one person out luckily
shoppers here are sensible and there's
no real tendency to hoard
wow a big difference huh
we've also got plenty of musical
instruments dan space and paper mache to
keep ourselves occupied but sadly no
weed oh
that is sad
what i really wanted to share with you
is that every night at eight people
emerge out on their balconies to applaud
the health care workers
wow it only lasts about five minutes but
it's pretty cathartic
[Applause]
and last week people decided to protest
the monarchy so we all went out on our
balconies and banged pots and pans
i've attached some audio samples of both
wow that is really incredible cool good
um
it's there's something really beautiful
about that and and
that is one of those effects that i
think uh
it's one of the
few positive effects that this has had
is just bringing people together and and
the the idea that we're all experiencing
this this
pain and crisis collectively um
that is really beautiful thanks again
for keeping up with the podcast and hope
you stay well and keep grandma jody safe
she's a national treasure uh hannah my
favorite name
uh she's the national treasurer she is
thank you for acknowledging that yeah
isn't that crazy that somebody this like
really wonderful person in spain
knows kind of knows what's grandma yeah
that's really cool um thanks hannah and
uh god i really hope you guys are
staying safe and i'm
it's
so inspiring to to read about how people
are responding to this where you are uh
thank you for for
writing that and sharing it with us um
and
thanks so much to your housemates i i i
can't imagine what it must be like to
create a health care worker right now
and uh heroes heroes the the danger that
they're putting themselves in so um
a huge huge thank you to all of you uh
who are working uh right now and uh who
don't have the luxury of being
able to quarantine uh like we do so
thank you and thank you for listening
and thank you to david harbor for being
yes um an awesome dorothy yeah
yes
and a really smart thoughtful smart
great guy
yeah really like him and i can't wait to
watch him on
i can't wait to binge him on can you
binge an actor yeah
uh i've never heard that expression
maybe
it seems a little weird it seems a
little uh it's creepy binge and actor
yeah
i'd like to see david it seems stalkery
you know i i'd like him to do i i hope
he does a comedy soon uh he'd be funny
in like a it'd be funny it'd be fun to
do like a buddy comedy like a two-hand
or with him like if he wasn't like twins
or something he's really funny
um
anyway uh i hope you guys
found that enjoyable
i can't terrible i didn't think this uh
and we'll see you guys next week see yes
and stay safe and healthy and
happy
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by christian long
and megan monaco
senior producer is michelle miesh lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louis
and hernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
you're trying to record that yeah
another off-duty
another off-duty mugger um
scenario
where from an off-duty mugger were
walking by
chris and i were talking about um
why the new star wars movies aren't as
good as the old ones is because
i was like and you get a different
different characters and the cool
creatures in in the new in the old ones
like empire you got both fat and you got
uh yoda and like then return you get
the ewoks
okay jabba and all the cool guys
and off-duty mugger would just be like
[ __ ] all right well and then i'm done
then i'm like
yeah
okay and then i'm off and i'll give
myself an extra or whatever
oh that would be helpless to get away
from oh yeah and incredibly so i
couldn't i'd just be like
if somebody came to mug me now just be
like
um you'd be the easiest oh yeah
i'd like i joke with them i would hand
them everything yes i'd start laughing
i might start laughing i wish it would
be maybe more difficult for them because
they get freaked out maybe that's true
the easiest amount of them is we're like
take everything we were polite and
efficient and we were like looking away
we were like exactly here's the i don't
think i would do that
i would i'm i would be like that'd be
scared by the way i know this is all
[ __ ]
my heart would jump out of my chest if
it happened i just imagined it happened
to the point where i might lock the door
like it's not locked no it is it
you